je salue Jenny Bastié qui arrive à
l'instant et je ne sais pas si c'est une
victime de l'instant Hidalgo ce fameux
instant
d'une certaine entreprise de transport
je ne citerai pas donc c'est bien
de la faute c'est une bonne chose bon
pour la dernière fois Elisabeth II
quitte le palais de Buckingham qui l'a
vu grandir et régner
lentement la procession funéraire avance
au rythme cadence et de la garde royale
et de marche funèbre
la foule émue n'a Dieu que pour elle la
couronne impériale posée seule sur son
coussin de velours
70 ans de règne que les britanniques
viennent saluer pour la première fois à
Londres
[Musique]
derrière le cercueil recouvert de
l'étendard royal le nouveau souverain
Charles III
et ses frères et sœurs
au deuxième rang ses enfants William et
Harry comme dans toutes les familles le
temps du deuil l'écureuil sont mise de
côté
38 minutes d'un dernier voyage solennel
et millimétré dans cette capitale que la
souveraine connaissait par cœur c'était
cet aprèm au passage du cortège
le blues de toi de tes silences tant de
excusez-moi de la reine va passer au
première nouvelle je l'ignorais
[Rires]
l'archevêque de Canterbury célèbre en
cours office alors que Camilla la reine
consort Kate et Mégane ont rejoint leurs
époux l'image de la famille royale
unique est une nouvelle fois mise en
scène
le protocole place 4 gares de royaume
auprès du cercueil la tête inclinée en
signe de respect il resteront jusqu'au
jour des funérailles tout le temps que
durera le lighting state concernant le
gardien des dizaines de membres du
personnel de l'ancienne résidence de
Charles à Londres ont déjà reçu leur
lettre de licenciement certains occupent
ces emplois depuis des dizaines d'années
beaucoup doivent être redéployés mais
l'annonce a été jugée du plus mauvais
goût alors que la reine n'est même pas
encore enterrée puis il y a aussi Center
Parcs les
îles de vacances ont des plans des
milliers de commentaires négatifs sur
les réseaux sociaux l'entreprise a
annoncé fermer le jour des funérailles
que vous y soyez déjà en vacances ou non
elle a sur sur les images mais cette
file d'attente qui était déjà
impressionnante et qui ne cesse de
grossir
pour pouvoir avoir le fameux bracelet
qui autorise à accéder à Westminster
Hall et à la dépouille de la Reine
Elizabeth oui et pour certains il faudra
attendre demain voir après demain
pendant les cérémonies officielles on a
croisé le champion du monde de la
discipline
et qui a flingué le plan de toutes les
télés du monde qui
suivent les
le passage du convoi de la reine
champion
c'est qui la reine des poires bah c'est
toi c'est toi je sais pas si c'est un
compliment en vrai
c'est une drôle de guerre que ce livre
depuis plusieurs années perroquet
sauvage et résidant des banlieues de
Sydney des cacatoès soufrées appelés
coquilles par les Australiens passe la
majorité de leur temps à chaparder la
nourriture jusque dans les poubelles
dérivera j'avais ce caillou dessus et
ils se sont débrouillés pour l'enlever
d'une quelconque manière ils l'ont
enlevé je ne sais pas comment ils ont dû
s'y mettre à 5 ou 6 mais ils l'ont
enlevé
tu t'es jamais servi d'un aspirateur
jamais au début je pensais
j'aime bien le balai tu vois la méthode
à l'africaine une véritable course à
l'innovation s'est installé entre
cacatoès et humain les stratagèmes de la
brique et du serpent en caoutchouc ont
finalement été déjoué par les cacato
excédé par les déchets répandus
alentours la propriétaire de ce café a
opté pour une nouvelle stratégie
ça c'est un verrou pour freiner les
cacatoès que l'on peut acheter
ça ça sert à quoi
mais ça c'est comme le balai c'est comme
ça engrais
et là tu fais
en même temps ok marie-fleurette est
stupéfaite
ce soir là pardon
les questions de ce soir on en a déjà
posé des questions intelligentes mais
celle de ce soir
elles sont mais là
et encore et encore et au-delà du Soleil